You may not heard of this
mention many acronyms for
Native Apps monetization but
they do exist.
Let's take a look at a few of them.
First, we talked about
in-app purchases a bit.
You may see this abbreviated as IAP.
Important metrics to measure,
especially with IAP are ARPU and ARPPU.
ARPU, or average revenue per user,
is calculated by dividing your total
revenue by your total number of users.
ARPPU, or average revenue per
paying user, is calculated by
dividing the total revenue by the total
number of users that made a purchase.
The advertising terms we discussed back
in the website monetization section
also apply here.
So if you wanted to implement ads in you
native app, we recommend you go back and
check out that content.
Now it's once again time to test
your memory skills with another
acronym challenge.
See if you can recall
the definitions for
each of these terms
that we just discussed.
Enter their meanings
in the boxes provided.